[Music]
this is the most famous cedar in the world
sacred both to the Jewish communities but
also to the farmers who naturally get
their hands dirty working
ghanfili slang skyview the business and
profit fruit
[Music]
my name is michele and I am
a farmer of
frizzy cedar  jesi since I was a child it's been a
family tradition my family
20 descended more than 60 years to the Jews the
rabbis come once a year to
cut these fruits
[Music]
and the m by e milan
in short
[Music]
ed
the center grows in other parts of the
world but at the same time this is a
very delicate plant that the cold and
it goes badly the sell goes badly the
great diva but that's why we
covered it with these nets to save them from
these the middle school must be  egypt
there must not even be a bondi it wasn't
perfect
different pasta children man size
and be clean
marques is
the
[Music]
second center are shipped in
second where I'm from the time new york
fr  ancia england
[Music]
are proud to carry on this
family tradition also the future
children and grandchildren
[Music]